this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this week's episode we're taking a look
at some of the most cursed weapons to
have offended poor jonathan over the
past year
yeah so this is this is a deliberate
effort to break my might break my brain
isn't it
wow
good lord i think i've just seen what
happens when a mexican drug cartel gets
its hands on time travel technology
jonathan and the whole team here at
gamespot just want to say thank you to
everyone who's watched the show over the
last year we really appreciate your
support and of course if you'd like to
help out the royal army's museum and
continue to support jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video and if you enjoy this kind
of content make sure to keep an eye out
for our upcoming new series loadout a
show where we take a look at the history
and impact of some of the most iconic
weapons in gaming from the shotgun and
geralt's silver sword through to the m1
garand and the desert eagle jonathan
will be making plenty of appearances
over on that show too so make sure to
check that out right let's take a look
at some of jonathan's pain and torment
from the past year
waving your gun around
oh hello what the hell
you did that deliberately didn't you
i'm gonna pause
okay i feel like i'm being trolled here
because the mp5 has suddenly
been customized to death as well it's
got everything under the sun on it but
an eotech site we've got a neotech
magnifier we've got a laser light module
some sort of foregrip modular forend to
take all of that and i think i saw a
drum magazine as well
possibly in a different stock so
just illustrating the lengths that one
can go to but um just because you can
doesn't mean you should
[Music]
that'll do it
so we've just seen our protagonist
retrieve
an automotive component from a car's
engine bay and anyone that's played the
game will know this is a cars oil filter
which is magically being attached to the
muzzle of this pistol this uh 1911 type
pistol now you can make
without going into any details a sound
suppressor of sorts
from an oil filter suffice it to say you
cannot screw it straight onto the end of
a gun it's also not potentially going to
last very long it's not going to be very
efficient as a suppressor the amount of
sound suppression you're going to get
from this
is going to be relatively minimal people
will still hear a gun going off
good eye
the sound suppressor is also far too
quiet it's not quite hollywood pew pew
there's a bit of meat to the to the
sound there but for gameplay purposes
obviously it's quite muted uh way more
than what this repurposed bit of
equipment could provide
awesome so we've switched now to the the
infamous deagle with the same um oil
filter sound suppressor on it sound
suppressors on desert eagles are um
rare
shall we say because there isn't much
point to the desert eagle in the first
place making it quieter is not usually
something people want to do
or do i can't let the clip of the
optical sight go i'm afraid sorry guys
there are no optical sights no reflex
sights like like we see here in use on
small arms in the second world war what
this is is a couple of decades of modern
warfare bleeding through to our second
world war so um get your modern warfare
out of my world war ii i suppose is what
i would say there
was
good lord
i think i've just seen what happens when
a mexican drug cartel gets its hands on
time travel technology because that that
gold black finish is
pretty horrific
i like to think it would horrify a
german soldier of the period as well
we're looking of course at the the stern
gover
mp43 mp44 sdg 44 with that horrific
finish on it and another nonsense
optical sight i think what annoys me
about those the most is that they seem
to be a default if you're going to start
surely you want to start with the iron
sights and then upgrade to the made up
optics anyway i'm starting to sound like
i want them to get off my lawn so i'll
stop talking
yeah so this is this is a deliberate
effort to break my might break my brain
isn't it
well um
they wanted a reaction and um
here it is
it's it's a firearm that only a mother
could love i think he's probably the
best thing i can say about it so it's
our old friend the the mosin or the
mosin nagant or the three-line rifle and
it has been butchered there's some sort
of muzzle device on it that i can't
quite see thankfully uh scope mount with
a with a 20 power scope or something on
it a light and laser module i i suppose
you could you could maybe live with that
but then we have a sawn off grip
sticking out the back of the gun wrapped
in blue electrical tape i think that is
and then the final kind of kick in the
nuts really is the uh ergonomic pistol
grip which is a contradiction in terms
when you're dealing with this thing
which is just a complete stranger to the
concept of ergonomics this has been done
deliberately and uh it hasn't gone
unnoticed right so i hadn't noticed the
laser on the other side so we've got two
lasers i think this thing would have a
modicum of merit if you ditch the scope
because it's clearly
even in the game i think it's easier to
use with the lasers than with the scope
and just try and sort of hip fire the
thing which lasers are you know that's
what lasers are for
not necessarily hip firing but um aiming
using the laser beam rather than the
sight they have their place but i'm not
sure their place is strapped to the size
of a mosin the gowns
[Music]
all right paul's out of the gate with
whatever this is
god i think this is a garand what have
they done to you yeah definitely a
garand action some bizarre very
1990s to 2000s looking sporting
stock ludicrous tank style or maybe boys
esque not really muzzle break on the end
there guess that would help with the
recoil of the cartridge it would did
they have them then no and we've got an
optical sight mounted over in front of
the action so at least we're not
blocking anything from functioning there
now we did have garands with optical
sights mounted on them but not in the
second world war the m1c the m1d were as
far as i know they may have been
developed by 1945 but they were not
issued and we have a
drum magazine because of course we do i
can hear john cantius garand revolving
in his grave probably more efficiently
than this drum mag revolves
what
what
what
what just happened i didn't notice it
the first time but we shoot this this
abomination dry and there's there's the
iconic ping we can hear the ping but if
you look at the action nothing comes out
except maybe the last case something's
gone wrong here an m1 ping without the
clip very confusing
the v308 v as in vector
but 308 as in 0.308 of an inch and if
you look at the side of it it says 7.62
nato the vector was designed as a pistol
caliber submachine gun or carbine
depending whether it's semi-automatic or
select fire like this one and it makes a
certain amount of sense in that
configuration pistol cartridges are
relatively low recoil the super v system
in there that redirects the recoil
downwards helps keep the muzzle rise to
a minimum and somewhat reduce felt
recoil that works with pistol calibers
it wouldn't work with 762. there is no
chris in 762 nato i don't know whose
idea this was i don't know why it's in
the game making it extra ridiculous
is the drum mag looks like a surefire
style drum mag the size of the cartridge
means it's got a big a longer heavier
barrel on it as well overall then a
existing wacky submachine gun turned
into a very wacky assault rifle the
other
aspect to this that's a bit of a a
rabbit hole to go down is whether you
could even build a 762 version of this
design the way this v-shaped bolt is
designed i don't think there'd be room
even in this stretched version for it to
actually function correctly
[Applause]
another curious design the so-called
assault rifle not super clear to me in
what way this is a an assault rifle i
mean you can upgrade it to be automatic
but it doesn't come automatic by
definition it couldn't be an assault
rifle because an assault rifle must be
automatic capable none of that i don't
think any of the automatic capable guns
in the game come as automatic you have
to find a specific receiver to allow
that which isn't quite how that works
but um we'll overlook that so let's
assume that it's an automatic version
and it's in 5.56 yeah it's a form of an
assault rifle but what is with the
gigantic cooling jacket which is itself
a puzzle because it's clearly based on
the lewis guns cooling jacket which is
an air cooling jacket a radiator
essentially inside an outer sheath the
lighter coloured flanges at the back
there are the inner aluminium radiator
that sits around the barrel
and then it has a
basically a heat shield over that partly
to protect the user but primarily for to
allow this interesting forced cooling
system where the muzzle gases pull cold
air in through those veins at the back
and over the barrel to cool it very
clever interesting system it's the only
gun that i'm aware of that did that and
it's on this assault rifle this also has
a filling port at the back for water and
a big old bit of plumbing hanging off
the bottom of it that goes somewhere
under the gun and does something so on
the face of it it's actually a water
jacket but that doesn't seem to factor
into how it's actually used in the game
so it's a weird mashup of lewis gun and
then it's got aspects of weirdly the
minimally light machine gun so that
lower receiver slash handguard is
visually based upon
the minimize handguard and the butt stop
looks to be reminiscent of the
collapsing butt stock on the minimi as
well although
you have to kind of squint so kind of a
kind of a cool star wars style visual
mashup of guns from different periods in
in our own history
wow
wow
wow
what can i say about this thing
it looks like somebody took a
welding torch cutting torch sorry uh to
a thompson so we've got uh ostensibly a
1920-28
type receiver with the cuts for the drum
mag although the lower is m1 we've got a
skeletal
machined out grip which you'll see
occasionally these days more so in games
in real life there's nothing like that
at this time except for the sten had a i
believe experimental only sheet metal
folded welded skeletal pistol grip with
a back plate so you didn't have to have
a stock on it four paratroopers so that
was real that did exist but didn't look
like this and it wasn't on a thompson
yeah the barrel's been cut right
back it's probably an inch and a half
long that's not going to do your
ballistics any favors i can't quite work
out what's going on with the foregrip
but holding this thing would be
difficult and uncomfortable and you'd
probably shoot your fingers off let's
see it in action
never seen anyone do a tactical reload
with a hundred round thompson mag before
having handled one and fired a 1921
thompson with that drum fitted let me
tell you simply replacing the mag or
taking the magazine off and putting it
on is difficult holding two of these
gigantic things in one hand
and like doing a retention reload with
them no if you were lucky enough to have
more than one of these mags i don't know
what you do um but you wouldn't be able
to do that
i don't wish to be too critical but this
might be the weakest
the weakest sounding
and recoiling desert eagle i've ever
seen in a game looks pretty close
to the mark 19 50 caliber but the the
sound effect isn't particularly punchy
at least not on my speakers and it
doesn't recoil like the real thing does
so i think we've got i think we've had a
limitation here of a third person game
turned into first person okay so we go
back to the classic third person view
with trevor here we see a much more
exaggerated much more accurate depiction
of how this thing flips at least the 50
caliber version how this thing muzzle
flips quite quite dramatically nothing
much you can do about that even if you
are quite strong so it looks much more
meaty and
realistic from the third person view not
great from the first
oh
good
lord i may need to take a moment on this
one tremendously conflicted because on
the one hand i've been wanting to see
someone put an em2 in a game other than
that fallout 4 mod that someone made
which looks a lot better than this so
let me get one this
is
an automatic rifle em2 experimental
model two and hopefully you can see why
i'm face palming because broadly this is
correct so like if you if i showed it to
you and close your eyes you might think
oh yeah that's all right but then it's
it's been dropped on its carrying handle
from a great height and that and is
weirdly deformed for no good reason the
pistol grip which should be this uh
carved wooden
thing is wood but then it has extra wood
coming back here that doesn't exist on
any of the real guns and we have most of
them here at the royal armouries it has
a checkering that was that never existed
on on the em-2
little details like the trigger guard is
quite sharply angled which is more like
the one on the later versions of this
the 762 nato versions where we brits
gave up on this short
lower power cartridge and went with the
american choice of 762 nato which is the
first thing that killed this
experimental design by the way the
forend the handguard is too short it's
been cut off too soon there's a really
bizarre birdcage flash hider that never
existed for this rifle so this is kind
of depressing guys because this is one
of my favorite historic weapons i wrote
two chapters of my book about it and it
also looked like this
not like that
and then we have this thing which is i
swear this has been included just to
break my mind there's no physical way as
if you didn't already know this that
this thing could work so it's yet
another pump action shotgun it's got yet
another non-functional hammer on the
back of it another non-functional bolt
on the left side which really ought to
be on the right
we load it by kind of wafting underneath
it implying that we're loading a tube
magazine underneath and yet it has a
drum magazine and the drum magazine is
mounted just under the muzzle and i
don't think i need to explain why that's
not in any way realistic
thanks again for watching if you enjoy
this kind of content please make sure to
like this video and subscribe to the
channel as we'll have new episodes of
firearms expert reacts every saturday
and new episodes of loadout every sunday
again please check out the links in the
description of the video if you want to
help support the royal armouries and
we'll catch you next time
[Music]
you